human's love of gold is kind of weird
gold doesn't offer much real world value
like a business or a handful of grains
so why do we hear constant ads from Gold
Brokers Hocking it on the radio after
jewelry Gold's main use is as a
financial tool because it seems more
reliable than wildly fluctuating stock
markets you often see the price jump
when fears are running high but before
you get tempted to dive in Scrooge
McDuck style you need to look at the
data in the 30 years between 1990 and
2020 gold prices grew by around 360
percent whereas the Dow Jones Industrial
index hosted 991 percent and since 1975
Gold's standard deviation or the gap
between its high and low value has
actually been around 50 percent greater
than stocks so over the long haul it
tends to perform worse than stocks and
has higher risk so always be sure to
take clearly biased ads and articles on
the stuff with a massive grain of salt
and do your research